so what can you expect when going into a
case study interview the interviewer
will often pitch you a business problem
we'll talk about a challenging business
situation that now you are supposed to
solve that you are not supposed to give
your thinking your structuring on these
business problems are often adapted from
actual projects that the interviewer was
working on in the past the purpose of
all of this is of course to not discuss
with you issues that you might very well
face that you might very well experience
in your work as a consultant as well and
of course now the firms are interested
to see whether you can handle these
problems whether you can come up with
some valuable insights some valuable
structures that would be actually
helpful in a real Consulting project as
well